[Music]
ten times
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
orleans pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children
the evil's growing it's coming what you
asked for is
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's going
gonna beat you
well welcome everybody today is a very
special day it is finally here it's like
christmas morning for the [ __ ] it is
the david pakman show member
town hall
now you might be saying well hold on a
second david if this is like a members
only thing
why am i able to see the stream oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad right well it's
wide open for everybody to watch but
today we will only be inviting our
website members to participate in the
town hall which is going to be at the
top of the hour i have a bunch of things
to go over with people before that time
because i was in
montreal
and doing different things and i have
not been streaming but we are getting
back to streaming people are already
getting banned which i love to see you
know it's not really a live stream until
people start getting banned and we will
start the town hall at the top of the
hour
now momentarily i am going to be giving
all of the different admonishments about
this town hall because already like with
almost everything people are extremely
confused about when is the town hall
who can call in
how do you call in
when is the town hall who's allowed to
call in who's allowed to watch when is
the town hall okay so we're gonna get to
all of those things
but
relax okay everybody relax we have many
many important things to go through now
you might be wondering david
there's a glitch you're glitching like
trump
why does it say nine members already
because nine people already got twitch
subscriptions just while i was playing
the various introductory introductory
songs one important question is if you
sign up today can you participate in the
town hall and the answer is yes
julie pollock just signed up
and stephen robbins just signed up and
barry russell just signed up
as well as maxwell ross just signed up
so even if you sign up today you can
participate here's how you get
permission
you go to our discord davidpakman.com
discord and message the bot pacman now
that's p-a-c
hyphen that's the bar that's up not the
one that's on the floor the underscore
the middle bar
p-a-c-m-a-n you message a screenshot of
your member portal on the website they
will adjudicate you a member and then
you will get access to the members only
waiting lobby okay very very important
you must do that in order to be
authenticated in discord
and i'll repeat that probably a hundred
times so that everybody understands it
okay thank you very much and thanks to
charles wheland as well for the twitch
prime subscription well listen newsmax
is covering the foremost scandal of our
time
it's the hunter biden laptop from hell
now you might be saying david trump's
lawyers now need lawyers because they
are participating in the lying about the
mar-a-lago search warrant and there are
now pictures proving that trump had
top-secret documents and bubba
no no no no no the real story right now
is the laptop from hell and indeed that
is what sean spicer is covering on
newsmax
it is completely and totally beyond
belief i think that as a result of all
this hunter biden's gonna have a really
hard time winning his election
what election i have no idea
but because of all the discussion i'm
sure this is very bad pr for uh for
hunter biden okay let's get into some
things i got a very interesting question
that did not make it into viewer
questions for this week and i'm going to
answer the question the question is
david did you ever have an encounter
with just an overtly racist person in
your life
yes
yes i have many many times
now
i have two stories i'll do these are
just two anecdotes okay these are two
anecdotes and i could give you dozens of
these anecdotes but i'm going to give
you two
one is antisemitic
and
jews
it's a religion and an ethnicity and i
consider anti-semitism a form of racism
you can call it xenophobia whatever i
consider it a form of racism so let me
give you two examples okay first one is
an anti-semitic example
some of you may remember that i once
worked at the now defunct electronics
chain circuit city
now
after working at circuit city i later
was hired
by a company that marketed high-speed
internet this was when high-speed
internet was relatively new some people
still had like the dial up you know that
no
that type of internet and getting onto
high-speed internet was something that
was uh you know sort of um for the elite
i guess you would say so the company
that i worked for promoting high-speed
internet would have me in different
stores sometimes they would send me to a
best buy sometimes they would send me to
a circuit city and once i ended up in
the very same circuit city that i
previously worked at
and
i walk over to
an employee who works at circuit city
and i was friendly with all the
employees there
and the guy says to me
i just had the most jewish customers
and of course as soon as i hear that
bang my radar goes up and i go really
what do you mean by that what do you
mean that they were jewish
and he says they just they they kept
asking for a deal like they really want
a deal
and i go oh right because
white customers don't want deals right
and like hispanic nobody else wants a
deal just jews want deals and you go no
but it was just like these people were
so cheap and i go you know i'm jewish
right and he goes oh i shouldn't have
said it in front of you
no
the problem is thinking this stuff
yes it wasn't a great idea to say it in
front of me but the problem the problem
was that you believe this stuff okay so
that's just like it's overt xenophobia
racism call it whatever you want all
right so that's one example second
example at our old studio when we were
in boston and we had the studio in
downtown boston
it was an office building with a number
of floors and each floor had a number of
different businesses and there was a
business on the floor i'm not even going
to say what type of business it was
because there's only one of these types
of business in the building and for a
while this was our mailing address and
people could easily figure out what
business it was but there was a business
there
and the guy who ran the business
he would often make
pseudo-inappropriate comments like they
weren't overtly necessarily racist but
it was like not so good he would comment
about you know the racial makeup of some
of the kind of like skid row type places
in boston and this type of thing and we
had this day
where i had behind me we had this very
old like 65 inch tv the tv just got old
we were revitalizing the studio i didn't
need this tv anymore and as some of you
may know
you can't just put a 65-inch tv in the
trash you have to arrange for its
disposal or find like an electronics
recycling day or whatever so i said you
know i don't even have a vehicle big
enough to transport this thing rather
than rent a u-haul i'll just call one of
these disposal companies you know like
my 1-800 my trash or something like that
and they show up and they get rid of it
so i call the company
and they make an appointment they go
serve with tears in their eyes they said
we love taking tvs out we'll be there
we'll take the tv out no problem
whatsoever so the the disposal
professionals show up and it happens to
be two black guys
now the building their security
at the lobby
and then there's security on the floor
and there's security to get you know
there's like a door with the doors
locked to our studio so it's like three
layers of security there aren't random
people walking around here
and this guy comes out of the the the
racist guy he comes out of the bathroom
and he sees
two black guys carrying a 65-inch tv
towards the elevator which is what i had
contracted them to do and he runs up to
me out of breath and he goes david david
did do you do you know that a tv was
removed from here do you know that
they're taking a tv
and i'm like you you mean the guys with
the 1 800 my trash shirts that have
passed three layers of security to get
rid of the tv that i'm paying them to
get rid of because yeah
like
those yeah they're they passed three
levels of security and they're getting
rid of the tv i contracted them and oh
and it's just so obvious and he says oh
i just
it looked a little weird so i just
wanted to make sure that this was not
what a burglary in the middle of the day
after getting through three layers of
security and having to go out through
three layers of security and i guarantee
you if it was too white guys this guy
was not going to express concern um so
anyway two little anecdotes
that may be more relevant to some people
than to others but
but there we are
all right let's get to some other things
that
have i been muted this entire time
the entire time i've been muted
i have been okay all right well too bad
i'll skip those stories let's look at a
few other things and we are approaching
the town hall at the top of the hour
thanks to erroneous as well as bernie on
a boat snappy tam and emily for the
twitch prime subscriptions if you want
to participate in today's town hall yes
the town hall is at the top of the hour
you must be a website member at
joinpackman.com and yes it is not too
late to sign up christopher brown just
signed up on my website
and so did uh
so did aaron houth
putting us today at 20
here's how you qualify to participate
in tonight's town hall okay
first step be a member on my website
second step message
pacman on the discord that's p a c
hyphen m a n
with just a screenshot of you logged in
on the website you will then be
adjudicated a member and i see we have a
number of different members now i also
see people in the regular waiting lobby
on discord today is a members only town
hall so we are not using the regular
waiting lobby if you're in the waiting
lobby you're going to be waiting a long
time like till next week it is a
member-only town hall today with peace
and love peace and love member only town
hall today
all right so everybody stay as calm as
you possibly can
super chat's coming in denver dave glad
to be here just said goodbye to my
sister who's moving to england and we
took a selfie watching your show
together one last time i'm definitely
not crying thanks sorry well sorry that
she's moving denver but glad to have you
here of course
always glad to
have you here
um people are in the chat are saying
they don't know how to get to the town
hall guys i just explained it okay so
here's how you get to the town hall you
get a membership on my website
you get on the discord at
davidpakman.com discord and you message
the bot pacman that's p-a-c hyphen m-a-n
with a screen shot of your member
control panel
three steps and then you'll be logged in
as a member you'll have access to the
member waiting lobby okay guys and there
is a command in twitch it's exclamation
point discord
all right let's get to a few things that
i had for everybody
um you know every once in a while
one of the things i like to do is to
engage with a troll
just to see
just to see like these trolls that email
me what happens if i respond and i
actually try to talk to them and i
regret doing it every single time
someone named stanley wrote to us on
facebook
and says
we found fraud attached to you you need
to come clean with your listeners about
your scam and i said all right let's
check it out so i wrote back great
please send the info of fraud and we'll
come clean no idea what you're talking
about offhand
so stanley wrote back and said i'm
sending it to the faculty licensed
department the fcc department
and i wrote back we aren't governed by
the fcc the fcc doesn't govern the
internet let us know the fraud so we can
investigate and stanley said yes you are
you're broadcasting
should have been you are right you're
broadcasting which fall in fcc
regulations and you're wrong you're of
course you're a subscriber channel as
well which falls into money's changing
hands
to which i wrote back
money's changing hands is under the
purview of the ftc
not the fcc can you let us know the
fraud so that we can investigate and
correct it and we never heard from
stanley again
so when you uh
you know when you try to engage with the
trolls
it goes nowhere
it goes nowhere
peter says what is a membership entitle
me to
and is this entitlement equitable
if no are you embracing capitalism
peter i don't know what the hell you're
talking about
um
the u.s is a capitalist country
and
this is a show where sometimes money is
made oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad right
now
a membership entitles to you too
daily access to the bonus show
daily access to the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
and when we have member town halls like
today
you're able to participate
in the town hall
okay
i hope that that is uh i hope that
that's clear
let's look at a couple of other things i
have to tell you folks this is on
today's podcast i love i love
the new
fiery
joseph r biden jr a reinvigorated
president biden
it's hard to dislike this let me say
this to my mag of republican friends in
congress
don't tell me you support law
enforcement
if you won't condemn what happened on
the 6th
don't tell me
can't do it
[Applause]
for god's sake whose side are you on
whose side are you on
[Applause]
look
you're on the side of a mob
for the side of the police you can't be
pro-law enforcement and pro-insurrection
absolutely a party of law and order
and call the people who attacked the
police on january 6 patriots
you can't do it
[Applause]
anyway i'm liking the energy i'm liking
the energy out of biden very much now in
the meantime this is so funny here's one
of donald trump's many attorneys now a
lot of trump's attorneys are going to
need to
get attorneys and maga as you all know
stands for making attorneys get
attorneys this is alina habba
she is now so
remember all this all the catch up they
threw at the wall to see what sticks
they threw at the wall the fbi planted
the documents and it was fine to have
the documents and there were no crimes
committed and the documents were
declassified all this different stuff
now they're going to the crimes trump is
accused of aren't really very serious
crimes okay this is alina habba
saying that trump's being investigated
for espionage and that's so mundane guys
it's so quaint
and
they say themselves in these papers that
they filed that this is under the
presidential records act so what they
did was to try and criminalize donald
trump as they always do they found these
three mundane statutes espionage and the
two others
guys listen they're coming up with stuff
that's so archaic like espionage and now
they're investigating trump over
something as minor as espionage it's
just a witch hunt guys these people are
beyond parody these people are being oh
they say attempted murder i mean listen
attempt it and fail you're really gonna
go after my client over attempted murder
it's so mundane and pedestrian these
people are really out of it and there
are reports that christina bob one of
trump's attorneys may now herself be in
some legal jeopardy
which would be um delightful it would be
absolutely delightful to see
super chat from papi says results in
alaska house special election coming in
at 8 00 pm eastern yes i will i'll
probably cover those tomorrow
uh curious to see where that goes sinsu
says when magga warned about violence on
one sixth they had a structure in place
to ensure that it happened should we
assume similar planning behind threats
if trump gets indicted oh yeah when
lindsey graham two days ago said there
are going to be riots if trump is
indicted what he was saying is our side
is going to riot if trump is indicted
it it's a direction it's a directive
let's riot if trump is indicted it's
absolutely bonkers
um okay so alina habba
um
ronnie jackson is like a week late on
the latest talking point he's going back
to the fbi planted evidence even though
they've already moved a few uh talking
points beyond that guys no one trusts
the fbi the doj
hold on let me turn the volume up
anymore i don't trust them any further
that i can throw that entire building
and so this is just their attempt to try
to stave off the special master who
knows what they got out of there i don't
trust these people at all they came in
they spent nine hours in there they
walked in with backpacks they kicked out
the president's lawyers the secret
service agents who knows in my opinion
i'm just gonna say if they told me that
they found something i wouldn't know
that they actually found it there or if
they just said they found it there right
trust this organization anymore the
american people don't trust this
organization anymore
yep
yep yep he's back to the wrong talking
point already if you can believe that so
there's ronnie jackson that's the same
guy who claims trump weighs 239 and is
six foot three inches tall if you can
believe that
here is uh trump's
um
almost soviet-style spokeswoman liz
harrington she says biden knew all about
the raid how much do you think the biden
administration is involved with this
specifically joe biden then again with
joe biden we're never quite sure what he
knows uh at this point with all the faux
pas
what's your sense about the biden
administration how much do you think
this is going to trail back to them
well i mean
similarly to what happened with the
russia gate right i mean it's mostly you
guys remember the russia gate mostly the
largely the same people
that were involved in the obama biden
administration and the setting up the
accusations of russia collusion with the
clinton campaign but that was all spun
into motion during the transition period
uh using you know this uh law fair but
also the intelligence community against
their political opponents so i think
they're very much involved i think it's
very much the same people
and that's what we really need i think
to your point david the answers to
we need accountability here the american
people have had their rights trampled on
they've had their border open they've
had their dollar and their economy
anyway so that's liz harrington it's
it's pretty much full on like beyond
parody it's it's crazy crazy stuff
thanks to nasty cues andre bavaria as
well
and dirt knap for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 23. there is
still time the uh town hall starts in
seven minutes if you sign up today you
can still participate cassandra wilson
and jim mcneal just signed up on my
website and are new members 24 and 25
also big thank you to joseph pierce who
just gifted a subscription and his new
member number 26 today speaking of joe
joe says via super chat david love the
show any updates on the finance channel
looking forward to it we are very we're
at this point we're down to just sorting
out like one or two technical issues and
then we're going to be ready to launch
the finance channel and i might even be
ready um on the saturday
trump rally stream maybe even tomorrow
night on the biden national address
stream
to welcome our first subscribers to that
channel
um significant information coming up so
we've got a lot a lot a lot coming up
let's see couple other things i had for
you don't want to do any more that oh
yeah the other day there was like a i
had a hair
sticking out horizontally during about
half the show like six inches out of my
head and i recognize now that it was
really really distracting to the
audience so i apologize about that
um
i did correct it during a commercial
break
when i uh noticed it but i do want to
apologize for that
it was crazy crazy crazy
oh yeah let me mention one other thank
you jaby jabby gatz uh with a very good
reminder
there is
a
uh an infestation
of
fake accounts on youtube
that are using my face as their profile
image
and their it looks like it's david
pakman and they are responding to
comments on youtube saying hey
i want you to dm me please dm me or
message me on whatsapp it's all scams
okay i love everybody
i am not dming with anybody i'm too busy
the only time i'm talking to people in
the audience are when people stop me to
chat on the street like when i was in
montreal more people than ever than
anywhere i've ever been stopped me on
the street in montreal some with tears
in their eyes saying sir i love the show
or
via the discord okay i'm not dming
anybody so they are all scams if any if
someone responds to your comment on
youtube says oh please whatsapp me or
whatever
report it as impersonation ignore it
every week i'm getting a dozen emails
from people saying david i dm'd you
and then i didn't hear back were you
trying to get a hold of me no
no i am not trying to get a hold of you
okay
who on the right would you defeat faster
in a debate liberal liberal hive mind
salty cracker or tim pool i don't know
who the first two people are so it's
impossible to say
cisco says david i was considering
purchasing a firearm for home protection
however my wife talked me out of it
given the state of magaz and fear of
political violence do you think i'm
overreacting okay so here is what i'm
going to say about this because a lot of
people have asked me
about my view on on the firearm element
and i have opted out of talking about my
personal firearm
ownership or lack thereof it just seems
neither here nor there from the
standpoint of uh of the show so i don't
talk about whether i own guns but what i
would say is the following on the one
hand
having a firearm at home is not without
risks
okay
sometimes
there are
negligent discharges
and people injure themselves or their
loved ones with firearms that they have
for home defense
okay
at the same time
i don't know that i want only the right
wing nuts having the guns like i would
rather there not be
this firearm
cultural
obsession in the united states and the
sick gun culture and all of it i i hate
all of it i would rather not be an issue
it is an issue
and if you say
are you cool with just the right wingers
having the guns
that's also an understandable concern
cisco okay so you've really got to
decide what's right and what's safe for
your family
but you're not wrong
to be asking a lot of these questions
that's absolutely and completely for
sure
okay
um couple herschel walker clips before
we get to the town hall let's see if we
can understand
anything that herschel walker is talking
about you have a huge following in
georgia
where you're from and people followed
your football career so closely there
and embrace you in a lot of ways
one of the things that
from your past during a really difficult
time in your life uh suggestions abuse
allegations from your from your former
wife and from a few other women out
there so you had to have known that you
were gonna see the kind of ads that are
out there right now do you wish that you
hadn't
run given this or what's your reaction
and what do you say to people who watch
these ads and have a question about you
now right
well i don't think they have a question
about me one thing you can see that i'm
very transparent i've been very
transparent people know that i've been
knocked down many times but i've gotten
up my ex-wife and i we're the best of
friends with her husband and my wife we
have done a lot of things together and i
did that to help people because you can
be walking around wounded uh mentally
but one of the things i want you to know
is as long as you see help there's
people that can help you but people want
to demonize that i'm going to be a
champion for mental health i will always
be a champion for mental health and
that's the way i did it but people see
where i'm at today where i'm at today is
i'm here to help people i'm here to help
georgians because georgia needs someone
to go to washington to represent them
honestly not um
all right kind of a interesting response
um
here's another one you don't
what do you see
as some of the big biggest problems
going on in our country today
i think some of the biggest problems
going on our country today we have so
many
celebrities telling people that they
can't do it
telling a lot of people oh you know it's
you can't do it like you got to feel bad
for yourself feel sorry for yourself
which is sad to me because
paul mccartney really recently told a
whole group of kids you can't do it
you know they've done it but they're
telling you you can't do it and it's
like god you did it why they can't do it
i think they tell our kids that uh that
you know they can't do it or to tell
making our kids feel sorry for
themselves
yep
no that's uh
that's that's a big big big issue
um and here's here's one more
personal walk is still standing my bike
is not bent so anyone can ride my bike
like he seemed to have chuck schumer and
uh joe biden riding his bike because he
seemed to be voting for whatever they
say
and that's of course a paramount issue
in the united states that if we don't
deal with soon
uh it could be the end of the republic
quite frankly so
there's uh herschel walker's insights
on everything that's going on as you can
imagine all right folks it is the top of
the hour it is time for the david pakman
show member town hall member town hall
this is the way that it works
today's town hall is open to website
members now of course we are live on
youtube twitch and facebook everybody is
welcome to hang
but we will be taking questions only
from
our members so first and foremost
where are we taking the questions
discord if you are a website member go
to davidpakman.com
discord you need to be verified as a
member in order to do that send a
screenshot of yourself logged into the
member panel on the website
to the user pacman on discord that's
p-a-c-hyphen
m-a-n and the moderators will get you
adjudicated a member now a few different
things
we are using the member waiting lobby
i already see people in the waiting
lobby who are not going to be called on
any parentheses or brackets in your name
to put yourself at the top of the list
will disqualify you it's a lame trick
okay i go randomly so it doesn't help
you and it's just annoying
also
the name format should be
your name or some part of it your first
name
and where you are
okay like for example
bobby from saint louis or something like
that all right if your name doesn't
conform to that i see
strange nicknames
i see brackets i see parentheses all
these different things
you are not going to be called on okay
those are the rules for today
um and that's basically the gist of it
all right so let's get right into it it
is the david pakman show member town
hall
today to kick us off
we are going to go
to cade from tampa florida
kade welcome please kick us off on a
strong note
oh god
kade from tampa you have muted yourself
please unmute yourself
and last chance for kade from tampa to
fix your audio sir
all right
did not work there
not particularly inspirational all right
let's go to mika from massachusetts mika
please rescue us here on this town hall
oh boy
mika from massachusetts go
oh man
all right
oh boy
let's try laura from southeastern
virginia
laura please
laura are you there
laura from southeastern virginia i can
see that you are muted please unmute
yourself laura you have a mute icon next
to your name laura please unmute
laura from southeastern virginia please
unmute yourself
hi
laura
hello i'm surprised to be called on
i'm surprised too but yet here we are
um actually i had more of something i
wanted to say to you rather than a
question is that okay well we do want to
focus on questions but i will allow it
as long as it's pithy
i have been very impressed with how you
have dealt with people
that call in on your show that are
neurodiverse
hmm okay
do you know what i mean by neurodiverse
i think you mean autistic
but on the autism spectrum
um adhd
um all of those all of the
developmental
um
cognitive disabilities
will i appreciate that
i wanted to say it's nice to hear you
i'm i'm not as far on the spectrum as
some
but it's nice to hear you uh talk to the
people with respect
have patience when their questions are a
little long-winded
and
it just makes me feel good about it
because i
um i don't like the way some people are
treated and it makes me hide my
disability because of it
well i appreciate that very much laura
thank you
well and that was all i really wanted to
say all right i appreciate your support
on the website thank you so much
thank you all right there we go
very very powerful first call
let's try
going back to kade oh no kate is gone
kate i'll go back to you if you get back
on
okay uh all right let's try mika from
massachusetts mika let's give it another
shot welcome
alrighty thank you for calling on me
david how are you doing i'm doing well
uh so in light of the recent news on a
gorbachev passing yesterday yes um i
wanted to sort of ask you how you think
about historical figures who
on the one hand have like unquestionably
um you know committed human rights
abuses um and have you know very sort of
like problematic past but also on the
other hand um worked for you know
diplomacy and allowed you know the
soviet union to sort of disintegrate
without any um extreme military
intervention on any of the breakaway
republics how do you think about uh
somebody with a complicated legacy i
mean listen at a micro level everybody
you know i'm guessing has things you
like about them and things that you
don't is that fair mika
that's absolutely fair so the way i
think about it with historical figures
is that but blown up to really really
really big and important things and so
with gorbachev and we we actually we
spoke about him on the bonus show today
where you want to make money but
everyone else who makes money is bad we
spoke about gorbachev today on the bonus
show
and we talked about the fact that
there is no record that is uniquely good
now that doesn't mean if you're hitler
but you also bring food to an orphan
we say it kind of balances out right
that's not what we're saying
but i think that
we're basically
i try to see historical figures
as
more
sort of intense versions of normal
people which is people are complicated
people have good and bad now if there's
genocide we don't equate that to they
were mean to you on the playground that
obviously has more significance but i
think it's it's to think about
historical figures as the just people
that they were
yeah definitely um that makes a lot of
sense i happen to agree
um i am young enough to have not been
born when the soviet union was still a
thing so that might affect the way i see
him but i overall see the diplomacy and
like i said the lack of violent
intervention
as overweighing sort of as contributing
to his being a sort of overall favorable
um good person
um
good actor in terms of history i tend to
agree with you mika
okay well i'm glad to hear that all
right and thank you for being a member
on the website no problem all right
there is mika from massachusetts folks
we are in a members only town hall there
are a ton of people
uh dm'ing me if you dm me to get on
you're just not going to get on there's
only one way to get on which is you have
to be a member and you have to be in the
member waiting lobby on discord you can
still sign up today in fact michael
whitney just signed up on the website at
joinpakman.com
and his new member number 28 today and
now gets to participate in the town hall
there's no trick to this there's no
secret to this but let's try to keep it
all
together and under control let's go to
liz from michigan liz welcome
liz from michigan welcome you are muted
yourself you have to unmute yourself liz
please
and liz from michigan if you are able to
i've unmuted you but you are self-muted
as well you need to unmute yourself
hi how are you how are you liz
liz you're on we heard you ask how i'm
doing and i'm doing fine now now you can
speak
liz you are on the show and you did
unmute yourself so it's just a matter of
uh it's really just a matter of talking
now
oh boy can you hear me i heard that
can you hear me
i'm hearing you ask whether i can hear
you but otherwise not hearing anything
else
okay all right liz it sounds like there
are technical issues there let's go over
to kade kade from tampa please welcome
save us kade
hey
how are you
i'm good hey yeah you called me earlier
and my audio was messed up i know but
i'm glad we were able to make the
connection i'm glad we made it work out
anyways i had a question about gun
buyback programs
and them being very popular on the left
and i kind of
i kind of see where the right is coming
from when they say they're not going to
work because the idea is
criminals won't participate
and that only law-abiding non-violent
citizens will be the ones willing to
sell their guns so it seems kind of like
you know it helps the issue of number of
guns but it doesn't really help the
issue of who owns them
and i was wondering your take on that or
your response because the intuitive
logic there is pretty sound in my
opinion so here is my thought on this
any one idea to curb gun violence can
easily be
criticized
with the following statement that's not
going to solve the problem and of course
that's true there is no one provision
that's going to solve the issue of gun
violence so you're completely right if
all you do is a gun buyback that's not
going to end gun violence because the
people who have the guns illegally to
begin with and want to keep them in
order to possibly commit crimes even if
it's a buyback where it's like no
questions asked about how you got it
just bring it in we're not going to ask
questions
the criminals will keep the guns sure so
you've got to do way more and that's why
i've outlined a list of you know 10 to
12 different things that i would do
because no one thing is going to fix the
problem that being said
the guns that people ultimately obtain
illegally at some point were legal guns
somewhere okay so it still is good to
reduce the number of guns in circulation
but you're right no one provision it's
sort of i mean listen it's sort of like
if you say
the only maintenance i'm gonna we need
to maintain cars and someone goes great
let's do brake pads we're gonna do a
brake pad replacement program
right but cars brake for lots of other
reasons yeah there's no one maintenance
item that will that will fix every car
but you've got to do all of them and
it's a sort of similar idea
okay so do you think a buy-back program
would be a net negative since you're
taking guns away from people who would
responsibly use them in most cases no i
really i really don't i really don't
because the you know these so-called
defensive yeah you're gonna take you are
going to not take you're going to get
guns
voluntarily from people from now
mandatory gun buyback i don't know if
you mean a mandatory or an optional but
in any case you're going to get guns
from some people
who are
no longer going to go to the range for
example but when you look at the number
of actual
verified successful defensive uses of
guns
it's a very small number and so i don't
think it's a net negative i think it's a
net positive by by dramatically reducing
the number of guns in circulation which
could be stolen or then sold illegally
or whatever the case may be
okay david that was a perfect answer all
right kade from tampa appreciate your
membership thank you for the support
all right okay it's gone thank you
uh thank you to by the way people
continue signing up you're welcome to
sign up today and get in on the the town
hall gilbert daniel
is our newest member at joinpackman.com
new member number 29
let's go
next
where are we going next there are so
many members here hoping to get in let's
go to denise from pittsburgh
pennsylvania denise welcome
denise
denise bailed let's try scott from
boynton beach scott welcome
hey david yeah
so
i hate fox news
despised more than anybody okay
but
and i would love to have them off of my
uh cable
but the counterpoint to that would be
my cable package also includes cnn and
msnbc right
if you get rid of one
don't you have to get rid of the others
well there's a couple different things
here if we just had straight up a la
carte cable programming where you can
just pick the channels you want they can
all be available
but you don't have to pick the ones that
you don't want and fox news is is
different than msnbc and cnn
in that it is significantly more
dependent
on fees from subscribers than it is on
advertising
and so if you just make all of them
optional
fox news is the one that's most at risk
if people choose not to subscribe and
pay for it so i say make every channel
optional let people choose what they
want
and
let the market decide that would be my
view
uh okay
i would i would worry that that runs the
risk of making it
if everything went all a car to make
everything too expensive me i'm guessing
i don't know well i mean
obviously that that's just the problem
of figuring out what should it cost like
i think i i don't know if this is right
but
i think fox gets three or four dollars
per month per subscriber which is crazy
considering so many people don't want to
be giving fox a dime now at four dollars
per channel
uh obviously that it's not going to make
sense but that's just a matter of
figuring out the right numbers
i got you and um one
one one's similar question yeah is
i i'm pretty sure fox is not
registered officially as a news
organization do you know if cnn is and
if they're not why not
i i don't know but i have to imagine cnn
is registered as a news organization but
i don't i don't have that in front of me
i can't say a hundred percent
uh okay well that's all i had all right
thank you appreciate your support scott
yes thank you all right
um okay
let's uh continue here
let's uh go to where are we going next
it is a member town hall and we're
speaking to folks from all over
let's go to patrick from vernon hills
patrick welcome
patrick from vernon hills you were live
on the town hall
and patrick from vernon hills it looks
like you may have the wrong audio device
selected can you hear me let's start
there
hmm
all right
well that's too bad let's go to jeremy
from the united kingdom jeremy welcome
jeremy from the united kingdom welcome
can you hear me yes i can
okay so i want to ask about uh inflation
or uh more specifically european
inflation okay so uh the war in ukraine
despite this
curse on offensive it's not gonna
it's not gonna end anytime soon and with
winter coming
and uh natural gas being cut off from
russia
i've read or i've heard more
specifically that uh inflation could be
skyrocketing here in europe i was
wondering is that going to affect the
united states
uh i don't know i mean listen my my
prediction and the prediction is worth
what you paid for it which is zero
my prediction is that we're going to see
inflation continue to taper off i don't
expect
um a resurgence of inflation
in the united states over the next six
months i think we're going to continue
to see those numbers decline
what you're talking about i would not be
able to say for sure
okay fair enough
all right thank you so much for the call
very much appreciate it and very much
appreciate your support
let's try eddie from san antonio texas
eddie welcome
hello david can you hear me yes i can
hey david um my question was regarding
uh beto o'rourke and his race
for the governor's race
um with greg abbott yes um i've been
seeing holes on 538 and he's i see he's
about five points behind
greg abbott but on the
as far as his chances of winning
according to those
to 538 he only has about a five chance
um would you agree with that assessment
where federal work basically has no
chance of winning the governorship sorry
so your connection glitched right when
you said the percentage you said that
538 says beto has what percent chance of
winning
five percent chance five percent okay
listen i am not a pollster so it would
be weird for it's like to disagree with
a poll it just i guess the question
would be if i if i have a qualitative
reason to think that the poll results
don't reflect for example the momentum
or something like that i think that it's
a very much uphill battle for beto i
can't say it's five percent that's one
out of 20 but it's a very uphill battle
and those five points
those could be a very solid five points
depending on how the poll is done and
how strong people are in their opinion
so i think the way i would say it is
beto isn't out
and i think that that would be a really
important race to win so it would be an
important one to fight for but i can't
say that i have different numbers to
give you than actual pollsters
okay all right well thank you very much
david thank you appreciate your support
there is eddie from san antonio we are
in the middle right now of a member town
hall we are live on youtube twitch and
facebook
website members are welcome to
participate today let's go to steven
from washington steven from washington
an on-again off-again website member
stephen i think is fair to say
fair to say david how are you i'm doing
well
um
this is uh
ronald reagan i'm aware
i feel like i was maybe being shadow
banned because of my use of
the the name reagan and you made it
clear that you do not like nicknames
oh uh no you were not shadow band no no
no by no me i mean we i know you as ray
gun
so
that would not have gotten you
disqualified but sometimes you know
people don't get called on different
things can happen
all right let's talk dad's stuff
does sam know you're calling in first of
all
what's that does sam know you're calling
in
i mean i always have to report back to
my handlers so okay yeah he he doesn't
know yet
but he
you know i'm gonna have to send him a
message about this no problem i just
want to make sure it's not going behind
his back all right talk to me about dad
stuff
yeah well no i mean i want to hear from
you i mean what's been what's the
you know
what's what's the good what's the bad
let's hear it the people want to know
well i was definitely you know i talked
about how in preparation i got like a
couple diapers and it turns out you need
like way more than that
you had like five yeah i was like five
diapers should be good for the first few
months and it did not work out that way
so that was difficult
um no listen i mean honestly the thing
that's been the most difficult is
constant panic
over like is the baby alive sort of
stuff you know this is our first one
the first night home from the hospital
uh we decided to do shifts
and the whole thing was like all right
let me take the 9 p.m shift um nba
playoffs were going on there was a late
game i was like i'll stay up and then
i'll try to push it till like 2 a.m and
then we'll switch for a 2-7 shift and
it'll be great and at 10 20
my daughter gagged i just heard coming
out of the bassinet
and immediately i'm up and you know she
had some amniotic fluid in the lungs
left over which is common after a
c-section and i'm running around with
this baby and my girlfriend wakes up and
it's 2 a.m we're on the phone with the
pediatrician and then it's just we're
just up you know we're like basically
running a vigil
yeah for sure i remember laying there
after our daughter was born and there
was this i'd take you know i'd gone
through all the classes and stuff yep
he's being overwhelmed with this feeling
of like i don't even know
how to keep this thing
alive like what do you i mean obviously
it's got to eat
um but
what are the other
and it's crazy with the eating where
it's like
we'll give her food and the next day she
wants more food
yeah that
that does not stop it's crazy for us but
it's pretty crazy is there anything that
you um
that you feel like you've i mean other
than than the diaper thing what i
learned about
parenting do you find your do you find
you're more
i i find that i'm much more forgiving of
parents than i was as a very judgmental
uh you know non-parent
adult
maybe to some degree but at the same
time like
i in some cases i'm more judgmental with
certain things where like i think on on
balance i'm right that i'm more i'm more
forgiving of stuff that i saw with other
parents but one of the things i have
learned is
behind every annoying kid there's often
one or more annoying parents that seems
to hold quite accurate
um
but beyond that no i mean there's
certain things we're like listen like we
just traveled right we did this road
trip up to montreal which is like
very very far with with with stops for
baby changing and feeding and everything
from new york it's like it's many many
hours and like i get why people might
just say i can't handle traveling i just
can't do it we're just we're just
staying home
but i'm like listen it was tough but it
was so worth it so i i i'm like no no
those parents who just stay home i would
encourage them to do the travel
yeah but david i mean to be honest
you're kind of in a sweet spot for
traveling because
you've got one of those non-mobile sleep
all day babies i know everybody always
everybody always says
at this particular age you're able to do
what you're able to do and i'm i'm
totally open to that let's wait and see
how things go and then i will eat my hat
if it changes
what are the other things that you
are
that you are more judgmental about other
parents on right now
um
you know what i i don't know i mean
there's nothing that i'm i'm kind of
kidding about being more judgmental but
i think that now having been in the
trenches with a few of these things
a lot of the things aren't that bad like
for and i'm sure it depends on the baby
but like for example figuring out some
of the sleep stuff like i read a couple
books on it and like
you know things go haywire but then you
adjust and you iterate and you you
develop a system
and i think sometimes there's like a lot
of people just have a lack of
information where like i really focused
in on like here's the five things that
are important to me let me really
research and be prepared for these
things and when you're prepared things
go way way better
so where are we at on number two
where are we at on where in what sense
i mean
is it on the table is it totally off the
table
what do you mean like where are we
changing the diapers what do you mean on
the table
i'm talking about baby number two david
oh i thought you meant like number when
when you have to change a number two
diaper
no no there is no discussion of baby
number two there is no discussion of
baby number two
okay is it the point of contention i
mean is it it sounds like maybe
no not right now it's not being dis
well it's just not being discussed
that's exactly right it's not being
discussed it's like how is it even legal
to have more than one is what's being
discussed right now
okay that makes sense hey let me can i
ask you a question sure well you've been
asking questions all along
i know i've got one more question for
you sure i'll turn to the to the boring
stuff okay sure so um this is my thomas
friedman uh corner okay okay so i'm
gonna share an anecdote with you
uh
i was talking to the lady who cuts our
hair for my wife and i okay and she's
she's from missouri she seems sort of
like vaguely socially liberal but not
super into politics but i asked her
about
the dobbs decision this is like right
after dobbs and all of a sudden she
sounded like
uh david pakman she knew all the details
she she knew about
the uh proposed constitutional change in
kansas she knew about this and that
and she was like you know obviously it's
something that is very important to her
and then she kind of circled around to
like uh something that i hear a lot
which is
like both sides are terrible
right
and i think this is sort of a default
for people who find politics like boring
or confusing or maybe not that
interesting
and i'm wondering
you know if you're just in a casual
conversation with someone you don't want
to get like into a full-on debate
what you would do what your strategy is
for sort of like
gently
pointing out
that like yeah there's there's like
shenanigans on both sides to be sure
but
you know
there's yeah i approach when people i
call that like enlightened centrism
usually what i will say is can you give
me examples of issues
where both sides are approaching
an issue in a way that is essentially
the same like not that they have the
same position
but that they're equivalent and then
they people will often struggle because
it's like you know the left wants
abortions to be
safe
and wants to reduce the demand with same
with with comprehensive sex education
and access you know all these different
things and the rights like ban it you
know and so very quickly people start to
realize it's really not the same on both
sides it's actually quite different but
it takes a little while to start going
through that but that's been my approach
yeah hey people in the chat are saying
i'm trolling you but i'm i'm not i love
you david
um thanks for all you do the p-tape is
real
and uh good luck with uh with your baby
all right thank you there is steven a
ronald reagan from washington let's
continue please folks let's go to
tiffany from miami tiffany welcome
hi david how are you i'm doing well can
you hear me i love your show david sir
um just a quick question okay giving the
structural advantages that republicans
have within the federal government yes
uh in the event of a unified republican
government house senate presidency in
2024 or 2028
do you foresee a national abortion ban
oh man do i foresee it no i i i don't
think i can say that what i can say is i
foresee
repeated attempts to get a federal
abortion ban i don't think that it will
get filibustered i guess i i can't
really say that i have a good reason
right now to strongly say it will or
won't happen but i think they will try
for it for sure
yeah i i kind of do expect it uh
as far as i live in florida i live in a
part of miami where there's a lot of
conservative cuban people here and
they're just
very strongly republican anything if
biden breeds they're going to complain
about it yeah yeah yeah hey listen have
you been to have you been to the
sandwitchery in miami beach ever i have
never been to the sandwichery i usually
hang out in wynwood i'm a little uh
younger
so most people around my age they kind
of ditched miami beach hang out in
wynwood yeah
there used to be this great
israeli restaurant in wynwood which
closed and it was what was it called
oh man you know i don't remember i don't
remember but it was right by the art
gallery area and uh some of the best
hummus i've ever had
really you know i might have some
friends that know about it i went to um
uh sorry university of miami yeah um i'm
actually from new york but i've been
living here since i graduated
well listen tiffany you've said it all
and i really appreciate your support
thank you have a nice day all right
there is tiffany from miami
we are now i think getting into
really the meat of the town hall where
the questions are happening
in a very very powerful way
let's go to caleb from washington caleb
welcome
hi david can you hear me yes i can go
ahead
so
i know you've talked about political
extremism
um
but how would you recommend combating
things like
people
using religious extremism
for their political extremism what do
you mean
so like for example
i know like there's some like alt-right
conservatives
but some people also
will be like con like very conservative
christian and that's what they will use
to
push their alt-right beliefs but i
wouldn't know how to combat those
beliefs because those are even more
ingrained than
than just political beliefs that may be
but
there is we have separation of church
and state in this country
we don't prioritize at least we
shouldn't
one religion over another or religion
over lack of religion and so i actually
think it's you know you might be dealing
with people who don't want to hear it
but the case against religiously based
politics and civil government is that
it's quite literally a violation of the
constitution there should be no argument
even you should be able to justify
what you believe
civil government should be doing without
citing your religion because that's
supposed to be a private matter
yeah because like i
i've
so like i my parents are like very
conservative
and they make me go to church i am
personally an atheist
but
like
i've heard the pastor talk about like
endorsing political candidates right
which actually is against 501c3 laws
they're not supposed to do that yeah
now hold on one second when you say how
old how old a guy are you
i'm i'm 19 but i have autism and um
can't really live on my own no but what
i mean is oh i'm your parents even
though you're an adult your parents
still force you to go to church
yes
okay have you ever thought about telling
them you don't want to go
oh yeah i
definitely but they say if i don't go
they take my phone
oh my goodness that doesn't sound fair
at all
i don't even know if that's legal since
i paid for it but
yeah how can they even do that so wait
you're an adult and you pay for your own
phone and your parents say they're going
to take it if you don't go to church
well listen yeah it sounds complicated
it sounds complicated and yeah i don't
want to go further in what it sounds
like but uh
uh i'm i'm sorry to hear that that's
going on
yeah it's fine but
yeah that that's
that's that's the background of why i
was asking this question well caleb i
appreciate you calling in
thank you for taking me call caleb with
a very
that's a big matzo ball hanging out
there they'll take the phone that's uh
that's dicey to say the least
um why don't we go to l from
philadelphia l welcome
hello sir am i coming through okay
you're coming through fine thank you
are you coming to me with tears in your
eyes
sorry what are you coming to me with
tears in your eyes to say sir i have a
question oh my god they're just running
down my face i'm drowning in tears i
suspected that i suspected that
um well i i guess i just want to say uh
thank you for the for whoever gifted me
the membership so that's awesome
and
i guess what i wanted to pick your brain
about a little bit and leave some left
over for you was um
i guess what i've been thinking about is
moving more towards
you know renewable green energy and i
almost kind of feel like
there is an aspect to it where
we might have to
kind of do
engage in a little bit of bad faith in
order to get everybody on our side
so i guess to get to the point um
say we found some magic way to get the
right and any kind of climate deniers on
our side by like i don't know
commodifying things that we probably
shouldn't um
but if it moves us in that direction i'm
kind of low-key on board with it however
um on his face it kind of sounds like a
good idea but
i
am having kind of a hard time going
through and thinking of what like the
downsides of that could be
i don't know that i necessarily
understand the question you're saying if
we found
some silver bullet on green energy
that
i i'm sorry i just i'm not sure i'm
following
i guess if it if it ends up being
something where
we kind of have to
trick them into thinking it's their idea
um oh oh oh oh yeah i mean listen this
is a classic thing from dale carnegie's
how to win friends and influence people
let people you want to convince of
something
come away thinking it was their idea
like i actually i actually think that
that's completely fine i mean we'll know
whose ideas they really were i don't i
don't i would have no problem whatsoever
if all of a sudden republicans go hey
you know what
there's a great thing about electric
cars and solar panels we can make them
all domestically and it'll make us
self-sufficient and it'll all be great
and we'll be alpha
homesteaders let them think they came up
with it you know i don't i don't care
right exactly and so that yeah that's my
question exactly or my scenario but my
my question is like what could be the
potential downsides of that um
honestly i can't think of anything i
mean a bunch of these right wingers will
think they came up with it but they
think things that aren't true all the
time so i feel like the downside is very
very minimal
hey um i mean that's what i was hoping
myself i guess only time will tell um
but
uh i yeah i appreciate your insight on
it well i appreciate your call and i
appreciate your support
thank you so much all right there is
elle from
uh pennsylvania
let's go next to elias from tejas
welcome
gracias
okay so um there was a story of of
mexico city being gentrified by
americans
how can we combat gentrification in
general and specifically also like
america is moving to mexico because it's
cheaper
so i wouldn't be able to say
how mexico can prevent gentrification
yeah i bet i mean in the united states
gentrification often happens because
there's a circle
of
housing becoming more expensive and
neighborhoods becoming in demand as
places where wealthier people want to
live to get to their higher paid jobs
pushes rents and real estate up it then
forces people uh certain people to move
out then the businesses end up getting
replaced to cater more to the wealthier
people that come in so you know
obviously you kind of get the picture so
there's a bunch of different ways to do
it some people say that rent controls
are the way to do it others say zoning
uh
i i think it's really a question that
is for an urban planner more than it is
for me i mean i think we intuitively
understand the problem but the mechanics
of what has to come first or i'm not
sure right
yeah i think it also like contributes a
lot to homelessness yes because if like
everywhere oh sorry go ahead no i didn't
no i'm agreeing with you
yeah um i think it contributes a lot to
homeless and homelessness as well and a
lot of like cultures and people being
erased
so i think really we really need to um
try to prevent it
what would you do to prevent it
um
i'm not sure i'm not a i'm not a um one
of those people who work in housing
right i haven't even finished university
but i see it's a problem because it's
happening in my neighborhood yeah so
yeah
um in fort worth all right anything else
you have for me
no thank you so much david all right
thank you so much for the call
we are in the middle of a member town
hall you can still participate by
signing up at joinpacman.com
we will do another wide open town hall
soon this particular one this particular
one
is a members only town hall and we've
spoken to people
uh quite frankly from all over the world
um i want to speak to
squaley the expat now i'm curious why do
you call yourself an expat rather than
an immigrant
hi david uh thanks for having me can you
hear me okay i can hear you fine
wonderful wonderful um well you know
it's um
in from what i've experienced as an
expat
it's the general term that um
people tend to call themselves but i've
heard i've heard actually that it's
it's referred to as more of an you know
upper class term or not not so
advantageous term well let me ask you
where are you from originally is it from
germany
i'm from upstate new york actually
you're from new york but then you moved
to germany
correct okay and are you are you a white
guy
i am a white guy yeah i mean from what
i've read
um
upper middle class and higher
white americans tend to refer to
themselves as expats when they move to
other countries rather than immigrants
i've heard that too i've heard that too
so i've been i've been you know i've
been curious about which term i should
use maybe maybe you have a
perspective um but i've been using them
interchangeably actually very
interesting very interesting well i
don't want to take up all of your time
without letting you ask a question
yeah no no i actually had a couple
questions for you david so first off
thanks for doing the town hall i think
it's fantastic um i actually uh have a
finance background as well um so i've
been following you for a few years now
um and i love what you do thank you um
so um first question is just more
general and if it's okay i have a second
one um but so the first one is i've sort
of been following
um from an international perspective one
might say like sort of the climate shift
the authoritarianism
that's been developing in many countries
and sort of the energy crisis so
those three on top of each other
climate uh
dictatorships and energy um so so so so
based off that i'm thinking david where
do i want to move next and i
sort of want to come back home to the
states but it's
from this perspective it's hard to tell
sort of where to go so i was i was
wondering if you had some some insight
as to um maybe in the next three six
months or even further like where do you
think
would be a logical place to
head back to the states you're saying
geographically or industry wise
well so so geographically yes but also
um considering the you know the energy
and the water issues that are going on
in the west uh as well as um
like i said the you know the the far
right movement sort of down in florida
right um as well as the climate so it's
it's kind of okay so let's see i think i
get it so first of all do you want to
live in a big city or not
uh
yeah so i mean new york's always been
attractive i like new york and boston as
well
um
so you do want to move to a city is what
you're saying
i i do i do i like berlin and i enjoy
cities and then how about in turn how
important is is climate to you and
weather do you want to live in a warm
place a cold place a place with seasons
do life seasons david i enjoy a warm
cappuccino uh during the winter okay you
watch seasons are you are you partial to
the east coast rather than the west
coast it sounded like you were saying
you are
i think i am i think okay
and then how about do you want to be on
the water or you don't care about that
i do like water
um although following the recent climate
news it seems that too close to the
water might not be a good long-term uh
investment
um so i'm thinking maybe a bit
bit further from the water but still
i do like water okay and then how about
as far as in terms of airports do you
want to be right by an airport where you
have lots of non-stop flights back to
europe or are you okay connecting
um good question um i'd prefer something
direct
so listen
i think it's potentially charlotte north
carolina for you i have to say
um it's still north enough that they
have seasons it's a few hours from the
water it's an american airlines hub
there's a bunch of different industry
uh and it's a city i mean i don't know
maybe you need to consider charlotte
north carolina
no david i have been to charlotte and i
i really do i like the seafood down that
way uh weather's not too bad um
perfect so thank you so much for the
recommendation um all right let's keep
it to the one question just because i
have so many people holding but i
appreciate your support
david all right there we go
uh it's sort of like the bill o'reilly
concierge service it's what it's it's
what it's become thanks to hippy chick
and jen jen here and kind af for the
twitch prime subscriptions and everybody
who continues signing up i want to say
thanks to matt de la cruz and luke
hollingsworth and melly beauregard who
have just signed up on my website and
now are eligible to participate in the
town hall we have so many great people
participating today it is really
it's beyond belief it's beyond belief i
think is the way i would say it let's go
to casey from oklahoma city casey
welcome
hey damon
hi um i know oklahoma's not the most
excited about state for anything or not
leave nelson but uh
mark wayne mullen is running and
presumably taking the
seat for the retiring gen
inhofe yep and the oklahoma supreme
court may rule on a ballot measure uh
soon about recreational marijuana and
the midterms and
i was trying to and i understand the
voters that approve the measure won't
necessarily vote blue but do you think a
state question like that can drive
enough turnout even in a state like
oklahoma to flip in off seats and even
maybe blankford's well listen enough to
flip is like it's too i can't say that i
would need to know more about the
dynamics and the margins in past
elections like it would take a little
while to look at that but
certainly certainly ballot measures can
drive turnout particularly in midterms
when turnout is otherwise lower
when turnout is typically lower
the additional voters
of a ballot initiative can are more
likely to make a difference so
absolutely
specifically whether it's enough to flip
the seats you're talking about you know
i'd need to know more about the numbers
sure and and can i make a quick uh
comment about the bonus show sure oh
please i i i know alex jones is upset
about the show but it's true that
several like current and former members
are too and i don't really want to get
into the details but the content was
just much different when it was the
boner show and
i mean will you ever consider bringing
that back i we are considering a
transition back to the boner show yes
absolutely okay very good best wishing
you and the family good health and i
appreciate you taking the call all right
thank you very much great to hear from
folks
all over the country including in
oklahoma oklahoma's welcome people
sometimes apologize when they're from
oklahoma or some of the places in the
middle of the country there is no need
to apologize let's go to our friend
johnny from boston johnny what's new
with you
um
lots of stuff been traveling and i'm
glad to be on
how's the baby going everybody's good
fantastic um
so
i joined truth central just for the hell
of it and i find it
kind of a hot mess and not in like a fun
way
you have like interactions how has your
experience been like trying to deal with
it honestly i feel like it's just a lot
of people watching stuff yeah yeah the
only engagement i got on troth honestly
was from people who are also following
me just as a goof who are just on there
as a complete and total goof
occasionally some right winger would
respond but it's basically a joke and as
of monday i stopped even posting there
because it's it's going down in flames
you know
yeah it's kind of like done it feels
like a
senior year project for some sort of
communication
it feels like you know how sometimes
there's these malls and they're like
it's a dead mall where like the
building's there but there's no real
stores inside
yeah like the hampshire
well the one that used to be the one
where there is now that's interesting
you point that out
next to the hampshire mall when i was
growing up in western massachusetts
there was the other mall which had like
the crappy movie theater it's been
knocked down now you've got a whole
foods and other stuff that it's that's
the equivalent of troth central now it's
the dead mall next to the hampshire mall
and they have like the one the one toy
like the uh rocket ship that you put in
a quarter and it works for 30 seconds
yes one toy yeah it was so pathetic it
was pathetic that's what truth has
become
uh it's awful i might just delete my
account because i'm not even getting
anything i can't even i can't even like
engage or fight with anyone i wouldn't
blame you i wouldn't blame you johnny
yeah uh one last thing i i i watched the
dish
did you get to work with sammy brown
hopefully get to work not directly not
directly
she's a she is so much fun so i hope you
get to work with her again
some people might not have heard but
like i'm on an episode of a reality show
you can find the info on my on my
instagram it's it's a wild scene
yeah i enjoyed it because just i've seen
tammy brown so many times live and she's
completely insane in the best way so
when i saw that you're together i will
pay the money to watch this
all right well johnny thank you always
great to hear from you
thanks david have a great one all right
take care i do want to say thank you to
eamon mckay
who just dumped in 10 subscriptions via
youtube putting us at 45 and very
importantly s prez dumping in another 20
via twitch and once you combine that
with braided dragon's new twitch
subscription it puts us at 66 and it's
an incredible thing uh i also want to
say thanks to mufaro
marutsani or maruzani who just signed up
on my website and is the newest member
on this very special day it is a
member town hall we haven't done one for
a while but we are doing it today that's
for sure
let's go next to smitty from los angeles
welcome smitty
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
okay great um nice to be on this is my
first time uh on your show can i ask
generally speaking what part of la
you're calling from
uh downtown oh downtown la you know
downtown la gets a bad rap but i've had
a great time when i've been there
yeah it's not too bad although
there's been a lot of theft lately i've
been down in this area for about seven
years
and my car has been stolen twice once
last year and once this year where are
you from originally
uh kentucky ah okay i thought i did you
didn't sound like a california guy you
know
yeah not originally from here originally
from kentucky well what's on your mind
today
so
i was just wondering um
do you think at this point trump is
going to get indicted and that he really
at this point has to get indicted
because it's just too
um
too bad if he doesn't and i feel like
i feel like we're just we keep on
watching a show that is really
you know um
it's like something has to happen it's
like if you're not gonna indict him for
this it's like you know
it's coming to a head where you have to
indict it's like this is all meant to be
for um
i don't know how to sound
um
i just think something has to happen at
this point it's kind of like yeah i mean
listen here's my view the gods the god
i think trump deserves to get indicted
and also i think that if he didn't it
would be disastrous at this point for
the fbi so i think he will will be
indicted but almost certainly not before
the election
yeah and i also feel that the people
around him every bit as much need to be
indicted as well it just seems like we
go through these iterations of his
lawlessness
and none of these people are held
accountable i mean literally well i mean
there were some in the beginning like
paul manafort and
you know those people but it's just it's
been a long time and people have just
continue to
you know criminalize
in my opinion
i completely agree with you and i do
think that listen i think the most
likely reality
is that when the fbi decided this is
what we're going to do
they they must have had a conversation
before of like we're almost certainly
charging this guy right before even
making the decision to do it
yeah no definitely and um
i just feel like you know it it has to
come to a point where he should have
been indicted already i mean yes
absolutely
and it's just
it's almost like you know the god saying
you know okay
we're just going to keep doing this
until you all indict because
i just think it's we have to face
ourself and we have to face our country
i
you know really the way i look at it i
could indict everybody even down to
myself
and what i mean by that is by not
participating in the political process
and not
uh you know doing more to make our
country great
so i even bring it down to the point
where i indict myself in all this
because well listen that's no crime
yeah but
you know it's really our responsibility
i think that it's also a message to
ourselves that we have to be active and
we also have to participate if we really
want the country to be
you know
to
we have to save it i guess is what i'm
trying to say i agree i agree listen um
uh uh have you ever been to the indian
restaurant in west hollywood called
badmosh
i haven't i haven't been to bed much i
recommend
i recommend it i went there with hassan
[ __ ] and stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii
my agent and molina and we had a
fantastic meal
okay i'll have to try it i i like hassan
i watch a lot of
a lot of his content and stuff yeah
hassan ordered multiple sodas during the
dinner which is something maybe to talk
to him about you know
well that's something i can relate to
him when i drink a lot of sodas when i'm
out eating fair fair and you know what
it may not be in west hollywood it
actually it is fairfax west hollywood or
no that's a different neighborhood
that's la right
oh it could be fairfax is kind of like
where right at the beginning where it
starts okay west hollywood fair how do
you spell it though
b a d m a a s h it's the double a that
gets a lot of people
okay yeah i'll definitely check it out
but i think i just i
have quickly become a huge fan of yours
and just
you know i've seen you a little bit here
and there but recently got a bigger dose
of you and i decided to join your show
and anybody else i would encourage them
to do that because
it really is a lot of really good
content really good conversation and i
like the way that you lay things out
logically you're very logical and you're
laying out you know your opinions and
facts so i really appreciate that well
smitty thank you so much i appreciate
that
okay
all right
from kentucky
now in l.a
with extremely powerful declarations
uh on this uh what is today saturday
night i guess it is let's see where else
are we going let's go to
is this david from colorado
david david from colorado or city it's a
city as well can you hear me yeah
yeah david from colorado springs how are
you doing man colorado springs oh you
know i used to think of colorado springs
as this right with this home of
right-wing nuttery because it's like one
of the main hubs of evangelical
christianity in the country but it's
actually quite diverse and there's a big
progressive movement in colorado springs
as well right
yeah it's pretty progressive it's the
groups i mean i've never really been
pushed or according to anybody that's
super religious or anything like that
yeah i would love to visit it's a place
i'm very curious about
very very pretty really cool place to
visit and way cheaper than denver
awesome place couldn't recommend it
enough well what's on your mind today
i just had a quick question i want to
get your opinion on something like that
what is one major issue that you fear
will have a major impact on your child
in the future that could be resolved by
politicians working together today
for example global warming
overpopulation some sort of currency
issue firearms etc global warming and
firearms certainly come to mind
education you know the the decline of
public education by design from
republican design yeah there's many
issues many many issues i could do but
you think for me it's global warming
yeah i mean the thing about global
warming is
if our cities are underwater everything
else kind of doesn't matter so that's
why it often comes to mind first to me
yeah and i just feel like there could be
such a butterfly flag that can't be
calculated by scientists today like we
could just lose one insect like it
caused it the craziest thing to happen
in massdep and who knows
yeah it's a little bit of chaos theory
for you i don't know if that's literally
true i mean maybe the bee but i don't
know but it's literally true but yeah
yeah like the butterfly effect thing
my pleasure thank you so much and i
appreciate your support great people
calling in today it's really great to
hear from so many great people thanks to
our rhino and breezy as well as mafi or
maful for gifting a subscription on
twitch all of this puts us at 70 70.
let's go next to josh in michigan josh
welcome
hi david can you hear me yes i can
oh beautiful
um well i had one question or two that
uh the first one being do you think
there's anyone
who um
[Music]
in the way like bernie seemed to kind of
unite progressives
and around the 2016 election do you
think there's anyone right now um
besides him who might be able to do that
like rally up people
ah you know i don't know and the the
problem with answering this question
is that um
no matter who i name someone will be
really mad like for like let's say for
example i was like you know aoc could
unite everybody
the more
center-left democrats would say no she's
too far left and is uh you know is that
she she would be divisive and then i
could go well you know who i think would
really unite everybody someone like pete
boot edge edge and then you'd have some
people go no he's too far to the center
he's so i don't know i mean listen
i don't know that bernie really you
you're saying progressives but i think
you really need to unite all of the left
which is bigger than progressives i
don't know i don't know um i do think
that as far as politicians go
i think p buddha judge is great i think
jamie raskin is great i think john
ossoff is great
you know there's a lot of people that i
think are really interesting but it's
it's hard for me to say anyone in
particular would be particularly uh
unifying for all of the left
that's fair that's fair yeah that makes
sense um my other question was my friend
and i were talking and he kind of has
the assumption that right now the
economy's kind of going down like it's
doing pretty bad but uh i've heard
recently on some of your shows that you
think it's doing well um
what points do you think can be made
that the economy is doing well right now
well i'm curious what what are the
metrics by which your friend says the
economy is declining
that's what i don't know um i think
maybe
maybe jobs because i know like obviously
employ unemployment is low right now but
i was thinking you know is that because
you know how many people right now are
working second jobs so yeah that's i
mean
that's a that's a talking point uh
that's repeated often but there's really
no teeth to it i mean here's the deal
with jobs in july the expectation was
250 000 new jobs there were five hundred
and twenty thousand okay more than
double we're essentially at full
employment in the united states right
now so i don't think that that's a very
strong argument i mean i'm open to
the economy has problems we have wage
issues we have inequality issues we
still have inflation there's lots of
issues but by all of the traditional
metrics the economy is doing quite well
right now
okay
well fantastic um i think that's it all
right thank you so much for the call and
appreciate your support
thanks all right
why don't we go next to teddy
from new york teddy welcome
just barely it sounds like you're
talking through either a voice modulator
or something very strange
all right let's see about this i'm gonna
put the other headphone in yeah that's
better
all right sweet you can hear me and all
that yeah
all right
um well it's great to be talking to you
i'm a long time viewer and recently
signed up with the crazy obama deal that
was a crazy deal yeah that's not
shocking it was great that was great
um well look i was i was gonna ask a
question about you know
economic issues you know i i'm a
a recent college graduate struggling to
make rent as as many of us are but i you
know thinking about what the last caller
said i think josh from michigan
uh about you know somebody to
unite the democrat democratic party more
on the left i'm really thinking about
stacey abrams
you know like
stacey abrahams i think has a very
charismatic you know outward appearance
but extremely progressive and practical
and pragmatic
i tend to agree with you i like stacey
abrams a lot and i think she's
incredibly savvy politically in addition
to just having the right views on most
issues
i would put her on my list as well
yeah she is savvy that's a that's a fact
and uh
so yeah there's that and uh i i i was
you know i also just wanted to comment
somebody uh earlier in the
live stream was talking about
oh you know right wingers and cuenon
people it's hard to get them to separate
the church from the state
and
you know i agree with you in that
it's unconstitutional to do so and all
that but at a certain point it doesn't
matter i think with christianity i was
thinking immediately about what
kierkegaard says about the leap you know
the leap that you have to make towards
belief
once you make that leap i think it's
hard to separate you know teachings from
reality and so i just wanted to make
that comment before i uh head up well
thank you teddy i appreciate that
all right man all right there is teddy
from new york
with a number of very strong
declarations
why don't we go next to adam from long
island
adam welcome
adam from long island welcome hey can
you hear me yes i can hello
hey uh how you doing david um
i got a
a short question and a slightly longer
one okay let's do the short one
the first one is what do you think about
biden coming out and and calling uh gop
semi-fascists it's perfectly accurate
and um
he's absolutely correct
yeah i agree
um
second question a little longer
um this uh the mood in this channel not
just this channel but all over really
the internet
kind of tends to be really cynical these
days and um
i tend to lean the other way kind of
cautiously optimistic about things i've
been there this is how i am
um
someone know what you think if there is
maybe an underrated component about
the morale
among
basically i guess the left and the
normal people of america who keep on
living in a democracy
um and if that that cynicism is
you know
yeah i mean
this is tough because
i think there are a lot of things to be
concerned about and there are massive
risks right now and if this right-wing
authoritarian slide
seizes power again
it is really bad there's a lot at stake
and also i kind of do agree with you
i think it's just by nature i'm sort of
like mildly optimistic that over time
things will trend in the right direction
so i think it's really a balance we want
to understand what's at stake
but not become completely cynical where
we give up
are you exactly exactly happy yeah
oh thank you for taking my call
appreciate it all right adam from long
island thank you so much
take care
there is adam from long island important
topic
absolutely an important topic for sure
let's go to um
oh i don't know let's go to sd from
dallas texas sd what's going on
sd where are you calling from
sd where are you calling from i just
hear background noise
sd what's going on there
oh boy
all right well that didn't work
uh wow that was that was strange
let's go next to matt from portland
oregon matt welcome
david is the sound okay it's beautiful
thank you
i apologize i don't have a very well
thought out question i'm a little bit uh
playing hooky at work here okay um
do you um have any idea what happened to
the conversation between um you and
coleman hughes i remember you talking
about that
some time ago
and i was looking forward to
we did it i i appeared on his show and
he was on mine
oh yeah but i thought it was
i don't think he's published it yet
oh is that true
yeah i think it's not published he's had
a number of podcast updates
and yeah look at this
uh
coleman hughes
that's really weird
i mean i hope you guys didn't have like
a giant blow up or something no no no
not at all that listen i don't know if
he didn't publish it i don't really
understand why but um
are you i i guess i don't know i thought
he did publish it i'm not sure
i will i'll i'll double check again yeah
maybe it was just a timing
timing thing but let's invest
will do but yeah i know anyway a big fan
of the show and uh i'll try to think of
something more substantive for next time
well i appreciate your support
all right thank you very much appreciate
the phone call it is great hearing from
people from all over let's go to aiden
from alberta canada aiden welcome
hello how are you i'm doing well
um
this is my first question it might not
take long because it's a hypothetical
and i don't know if you like to go too
deep into those but it's basically i'm
just wondering if you think there's
any chance there's a connection between
the
missing secret service texts and the
documents found at mar-a-lago
not that i can connect right now i mean
i wouldn't rule anything out but no what
would the connection be
well i don't know how this would even
take place but i'm just wondering if
trump
somehow got the text deleted and then
took the
copies of them or something to
mar-a-lago like physical copies but i
don't even know it seems far-fetched and
i'm not even aware of any of the
documents being
text messages you know
okay no problem i just a quick another
question uh i'm kind of uh i guess
uh
i would like to be a filmmaker one day i
know you like documentaries and i'm
wondering if you've ever seen any
documentaries that have like really
changed your view on a topic
and uh in your opinion what kind of
makes uh what makes a story
uh
more persuasive than others in your
opinion i guess
wow that's a really good question that i
am wholly unprepared to answer i mean
yes tons of documentaries i've seen
have shifted my view on things i don't
know about like a total 180 but
certainly i've had shifts in my views on
things from documentaries i've seen what
makes them
i mean i think
when they at least are
when they at least appear to be
both
extremely honest
and well researched
i think that those are the two
components that go the you know some of
them
yeah uh
you some of them are extremely
emotionally edited but you just don't
buy what they're selling and in that
case they're not particularly
influential so i think it has to be in
all of the above
awesome
yeah no i just wanted to get your
thoughts on that i know i'm kind of
putting you on the spot there but yeah
have a good rest of your show and i'll
be i'll be listening all right thank you
so much i really appreciate that
that's that's great to hear i want to
say thanks to tom hixson who just signed
up at joinpacman.com and his new member
number 71 today
let's speak to more people it is the
david pakman show members only town hall
all are welcome to watch
but today
we are only welcoming our members let's
listen to our friend francois from
montreal
uh welcome back francois
david sir it's nice to talk to you again
likewise
so uh i was listening to your
award-winning bonus show where you want
to make money yes uh it sounds like you
had quite the montreal trip
it was a beautiful trip you know i've
been to montreal 20 times
and it's really great i met up with um
mp anthony house father who represents
the western part of montreal he watches
the show we went for a beautiful walk
and talked about canadian politics and
so many different things the food was
great i had some great pastries and uh
visited family it was just a great trip
yeah well i'm bummed i wasn't in town
all the last week but i would love to
run into it sounds like you uh met up
with lots of different people but you
know it was i would come out i would
come out of a depp as you guys call them
and people would be there saying david
sir welcome and then i was where else
was i i was i was on the street at one
point walking up and down
urgently looking for a place to go to
dinner before my daughter completely
threw a temper tantrum and someone came
up to me and said david hey and it was
just all over the place it was wild
so it's fair to say you experienced uh
many elements from the standpoint of
montreal i think i would i couldn't i
could not possibly deny that yeah
all right well actually it's funny my
question relates a bit to what you were
just talking about um i thought that was
quite interesting that you spent some
time with the anthony house father yeah
uh so i guess did you
meet just from uh him being a fan of
your show
yeah we just follow each other on uh on
twitter and and i told him i'm gonna be
in town and he said let's uh let's meet
up
oh cool so you guys talk about some i
guess u.s politics canadian politics
that kind of stuff yeah all completely
informally you know
yeah i mean i know american politics is
obviously your specialty but i'd be
definitely interested in hearing more of
your thoughts on canadian politics maybe
one day or maybe next time we have an
election yeah i mean i just i don't know
there's so many people far better suited
to comment on it you know i don't want
to be out of my lane like who am i to
comment on canadian politics you know i
mean i i can't i know we could use the
we could use a david pakman in uh in
canada like a similar sort of
progressive uh online
podcast show that would be nice that's
fair
get like an on-the-ground canadian beat
going since i know you'd spend a lot of
time up in montreal yeah i would i would
consider doing that yeah listen where
where are you on poutine at this point
pro or against
oh of course i'm pro poutine but it's
gonna be uh you know it's i don't like
to mess with it too much i know there's
a lot of people i mean la bonkeys you've
probably heard of it possibly have been
there and one of the more famous poutine
establishments what was the name of it
oh i have not been no i've not heard of
it
oh really okay well it's definitely
considered the more like uh
highly recommended tourist poutine place
it's uh it's in the plateau oh see i
don't want tourist poutine i want i want
local people so that's the thing that's
the i mean it
it is a local place it's not like it's a
chain or anything but i um
you know my opinion on poutine's evolved
a lot over the years i used to like that
place but you know that's uh
they kind of go a little bit crazy with
it you can get poutines with all sorts
of meat on it i think there's like a
mexican one that comes with guacamole oh
they're completely adulterating it
that's what i think you know the the
older i get and the more poutines i have
the more i want to stick to just a real
classic yeah fries real real hot gravy
get the squeaky cheese i agree you know
there's places that are completely
bastardizing your pastrami on rye with
mustard and they start doing all sorts
of extraneous toppings and wild things
it's like what's good about it is the
simplicity you put it on either rye
marble rye or pumpernickel
you've got your pastrami you've got deli
mustard if you want swiss on it that's
fine but we don't need to go crazy just
because it's 20 22.
couldn't agree more what's your take on
schwartz's
you know i tried to go to schwartz's
when i was just in in montreal the line
was two blocks and i have got a 12 week
old daughter you know so i had to i had
to abort the the trip over there
understandable well let me give you a
little tip maybe i don't know if you
noticed this when you were there but
there's actually two doors there's the
main door that the lineup is going into
there's a door right next to it that
doesn't often have a line it's for the
take out but there's actually even
tables to eat in the takeout
establishment is that right a little
local tip for you next time you're here
i'm gonna have to examine that now just
one other montreal thing i used to love
this cocktail bar big in japan are you
familiar with that
i live right around the corner from
where it used to be right and it's it
seems that it's just gone
i believe it is there were two locations
at one point one was the cocktail bar
one was the restaurant i think only the
restaurant remains although i might i
might be mistaken about that too yeah
we'll have to look into it very strongly
well i found another one there's a
there's a cocktail bar called the cold
room where you have to send a text and
they they let you in some filthy back
door and through some the back of some
restaurant and all of a sudden this
beautiful cocktail bar opens up like in
like the double basement of some place
yeah that was uh you said you were
staying down there right in the old port
i was in the old port yeah yep yep yeah
i'm surprised a a veteran of montreal
travel like yourself would stay down
there and i'm not surprised to hear
about that whole debacle that unfolds
yeah here's the thing i've completely
outgrown the old port neighborhood i
really like saint henry i thought that
was a you know kind of brooklyn-like
neighborhood and there's all these other
areas but just because of what what i
was doing and the people i was visiting
it was the most convenient place
oh yeah well you know sometimes you have
to make sacrifices it was a sacrifice it
was a sacrifice all right my friend well
thank you for the call
yeah pleasure to speak with you as
always front swap from montreal great to
hear from him
let's hear from oh i don't know let's
come back to the united states
and maybe talk to
oh who knows it's uh there's just so
many folks here how about tommy from
wisconsin tommy welcome
all right
hello
hello
yeah
can you hear me
yes i can
okay i guess i had one question for you
if you
had
the oversight on the
plan the
inflation lowering plan what would you
set the minimum corporate tax percentage
at
would you say minimum corporate tax oh
for what income
see for me i i think it should be i
think it probably should be progressive
i think for a small business it i would
set a different minimum tax than for a
larger business and the trick of it is
you also
have to consider
what counts as a deductible expense and
what doesn't for the purposes of a
minimum tax that it's a very complicated
question i wouldn't be able to give you
just one number
sure yeah and you know you look at it
it's like oh well the percentage is
going up for you know to 15 but i
believe
somewhere on the bill it's for
you know profits over a billion dollars
so it really doesn't include
i would even say the majority of the big
companies right i mean a company that's
making a hundred million should still be
subject to that and you could argue that
it should be a different percentage but
yeah no i i think it's
it was done in a way where it's
relatively inoffensive to the vast
majority of businesses although of
course it's targeting the very very big
ones
sure absolutely and one comment i had
from your podcast today you had
mentioned that many or some of the
documents from mar-a-lago were ripped up
yeah that's because it's they're easier
to flush once they've been ripped
absolutely you can't flush full sheets
of paper in the same way that you can
flush little shreds
yeah absolutely it's very difficult so
you would be flushing 10 to 15 times no
no no no absolutely not you could
probably get with a five flusher you can
get the shreds down yeah
great all right thank you call david
thank you very much appreciate that all
right everybody that's gonna do it for
this members only town hall we will very
soon be scheduling another
regular town hall at which members will
still get priority but we will open it
to everyone we have two more streams
over the next three days tomorrow night
i will be with you for joe biden
addressing the nation
and then saturday i will be with you for
the failed former president trump
trying to use language to communicate
which should be quite a scene alright
everybody thank you for joining me see
you back here very very soon